i just wanted to give a huge shout out
to torbesta he gave me the idea for this
video and basically without his video i
wouldn't be making this one so make sure
you go over the one i linked in the
description and give it a like
what is going on guys this is
statistically challenged and today i
have another video for you guys today we
are going to be doing one hour of wiring
running now there are only a couple
requirements to start wyvern running the
first one is you'll need a cash stack of
at least over 100 000 gp in my opinion
for it to be worth it there are a bunch
of ways to make over 100 thousand gp on
my channel in an hour so go to my videos
and check them out secondly i really
recommend you get a house in remington
all you need for that is one
construction go to falador talk to the
estate agent and buy your house for 1000
gp once you've done that the last and
final requirement which is actually a
mandatory one in my opinion these things
only cost around 2000 gp in the ge now
the only requirement you need to wear
one is completing elemental workshop one
which doesn't require very high stats
and it's a relatively fast quest to get
out of the way once we have all those
things we can start preparing for the
wyvern running itself now the first
thing you're going to want to do is join
a cc called wyvern cc that's with no
space just like this you're going to
join it and you're going to see a bunch
of people
i want to give a huge shout out to the
cc i was talking to one of the
moderators ranks in it his name is
temptation4 as you can see we had a long
private chat log he gave me a bunch of
tips because he's been doing this for a
while and i just wanted to give a shout
out to the cc and him for helping me out
and basically letting me do this video
what i'm going to be buying is nothing
more than just a couple ranging pots
probably six range pots for the first
trip i'm just gonna get a couple of
house tabs now just so i don't have to
buy them later i think that is all i
really need for now guys i don't want to
over complicate stuff i want as many
inventory spots as i can because it
seems like in the clan chat a lot of
people
have pea pods for sale and i think
that's where the most of the profits
gonna come from so we're going to start
the timer
after we arrive at the wyvern cave so to
get there all you're gonna do is break
your house tab and you're going to end
up in remington if we open up the world
map right now you can see the wyvern
cave is just south east
right here at the dungeon so i'm going
to just quickly speed me up running to
there
all right once you're here you're just
gonna climb down trap door then you will
be in a cave
very easy to run to the wyverns you just
have to run right over here as you can
see this is ice warriors and giants you
want to come right down here so it's
just
north and then you take the first east
passage
[Music]
again if this is your first time doing
it like me i recommend you have the
reddit page open of the price guys for
the items so that you guys give them a
fair deal without further ado guys we're
going to start timer right now again
make sure you are in wyvern cc because
this is the only way you're going to
know who's selling stuff and we're going
to start right now so this guy's selling
renar in world 6. as you can see when
you trade them what you're going to want
to do is stand right behind them
and then just give them a quick trade
they say the bernards i'm going to give
them 4k for the renar and yeah we just
made 3k just like that guys but as you
guys can see there's a lot of other
people doing this right now
so competition is up boys to renard's
loop 307 so as you guys can see right
when that call comes into the clan chat
we're gonna hop
and we got there first actually we beat
the other runner
all right so this guy had a loop
so i'm just gonna give him
i'm just gonna give him 12k i don't know
what the price is that's half of it i
think that's a good deal all right we
are here
give me everything you have all right so
6kp pots
at four at 5k each is 30k right there
33k for the bones
i believe it's 33k
holy [__] okay that's actually that's
actually really good profit that was a
really good world right there all right
so someone's actually calling for range
pots at 356. this is a 1500 world so a
lot of the other
runners can't actually get here so i
have the advantage
[Music]
thank you for that sir guy wants three
as well on the exact same world so we're
gonna do that for him real quick dude
that's such a good profit honestly man i
love this method because you're helping
people out and you're getting a lot of
profit in return and it's really worth
it for these people because then they
can just stay here for as long as they
want dude get me on that dude this is so
quick this is honestly very quick okay
that guy immediately got taken all right
so unfortunately i only have one range
pot
thank you very much
[__] yeah boys so we almost have a full
inventory i'm just gonna cut to when i
have a full inventory and get back to
you guys when i do okay guys so we just
got our last trade
now we're going to break the house tab
and i'm going to be showing you the
process which you could bank this is not
mandatory but this is the one i use
we're going to go to world 30 right now
to the house party world and then once
i'm here i go into max house
i just want to give a huge shout out to
drew jay right here as you guys can see
him this guy's a beast his house is open
12 hours a day at world 30 so if you
ever need to use one use this guy's max
house boys it's [__] epic
but yeah we use his ornament kit and the
pool
we just made 124k in 10 minutes with
just one run and i'm not even that good
at this okay guys so we're on our way
back to the wyburn cave i'll talk to you
guys in a bit i might just cut to the
next inventory and see how fast i can
get it in if i was quicker of course you
know i could be getting faster
inventories but for my first time i
think 124k in just 10 minutes is really
good so i think this video is going to
make absolute bank oh yeah by the way i
just realized now that i don't have any
range pots so we won't be able to sell
any range pots but that's fine because a
lot of people sell stuff anyways but for
the next inventory i'm definitely going
to pack a couple range pots just in case
because you can get some killer deals
when you have them all right guys so i'm
just going to call that the inventory
there because i really want to get some
broad bolts and range pots
i don't really know why
i didn't uh bring those beforehand but
yeah i didn't know people actually
bought broad bolts it makes sense now
obviously because you run out and i
think those have a huge margin on the
website so yeah that inventory we made a
lot less we only made like 50k but
that's fine because half of it was just
vibrant bones anyways no since someone's
actually buying broad bolts i'm actually
just gonna stay with the ranging pots
and just start buying stuff out from
people all right guys so this is why i
said it would be worth bringing the
range pots look at that that's a 24k
profit right there
yeah so these are the range pods are
definitely good because a lot of people
don't bring them i think and they only
buy stuff so if you're gonna do this
bring range pots it really it really
pays off in the end yeah okay another
sick trade got 17k worth of wyvern bones
for just 8k [__] bullet
holy [__] [__] boys we are getting
really fast within seconds were people
selling stuff you know this is all about
speed and beating the other runners but
sometimes if you're the only runner here
this could probably be north of like
mills mills per hour
so you guys if you're going to be a
runner by the way and someone gets to
the player first be sure to be
respectful and let them you know buy
whatever or sell whatever they're doing
it's just you know it's a respect thing
and don't be afraid to ask the cc if
they need anything like range pots
because as you guys can see i asked the
cc this guy needs range pots and this
guy gladly bought two of them for a
chaos alright guys so after selling that
we were past the 250k profit market
we're just halfway so what i'm gonna do
now is actually invest in some nature
runes some people were buying alex
before so yeah this guy
what i've noticed is that everyone here
is very kind like
this guy i promised him that i'd be here
with four range bots and this other guy
came to try to basically you know sell
them before me but this guy actually
respected me and sold them to me you
know even though this guy was there
first the cc's integrity and respect for
players is pretty high all right guys so
there is 60k per 100 alex but i'm
cutting this guy a good deal just
because he's the only one who's actually
buying them
all right guys so just hit the 50 minute
mark 30 seconds ago we're done another
inventory so far i really love this
method
i'm not that good at it so at the end of
the hour you know my profit may not be
as high as some of you guys get but you
know keep in mind this is my first time
so with experience and speed you guys
can accomplish sick money per hour doing
this but yeah guys if we price check the
nature rooms and what we have now we are
almost 400k
in absolute profit so we've got one more
inventory coming up can we make it 500k
in the hour another killer dealer guys
you can see 17k profit off that doesn't
get much better than that to be honest
so yeah guys if you ever have trouble
attacking the wyverns you can always
climb up these steps so that you guys
can trade in peace just saying yeah
another baller trade you know the
inventory is going up quick boys i mean
five minutes left we're gonna see if we
can sell all these range spots and get
it filled up before the timer runs and
then we'll see how much profit we've
accumulated at the end alright guys so
we are coming up to the end of the hour
and it doesn't seem like i'll be able to
get rid of the alex or the range pop but
i filled my inventory up pretty well we
are going to stop the timer on the hour
right there guys we've just done one
hour of why we're running now we're just
gonna go back to the grand exchange and
sell all of it and see how much money we
made again shout outs to my man drew g
for letting us use the beastly house for
these wyvern trips there he is
alright so we're gonna hit collect on
all that and
at the end of the hour sadly we couldn't
predict the 500k mark but guys at the
end of the hour we profited 471k
326 gp i honestly enjoyed making this
video because it was pretty chill just
like going around hopping to people and
everyone's pretty nice at the wyvern
caves when they're doing these and
they're trying to buy supplies off
wyvern runners again guys massive shout
out to wyvern cc none of this would have
been possible if the cc didn't have such
a great community that offers these
services like wyvern running if you guys
are doing wireds yourself be sure to
join this clan chat and if you guys want
to make money the way i did in this
video then don't be afraid to just join
the cc and ask people if they need
supplies and go help them out you know
at the end of the day everybody wins
because the runners make money off it
and the people training range can sit
there for as long as they want i'm gonna
leave the cc name in the description and
their reddit page because they update it
frequently and they have all the prices
there plus the rules make sure you go
check them out they're freaking awesome
if you guys enjoyed this video be sure
to subscribe i'm gonna probably release
another tomorrow so yeah don't forget to
leave an honest rating on how you think
the video is done until next time guys
have a good day
[Music]